en marge de la compétition sportive le
mondial a engendré une autre forme de
compétition plus feutrée celle là entre
le premier ministre et le président de
la république qui depuis le début du
mois de juin soit dit respectueusement
se marquent à la culotte comme disent
les spécialistes damien thévenot vincent
foucades coup de sifflet final hier soir
les bleus l'emportent
l'entraîneur aimé jacquet est soulagé
jacques chirac exulte
une belle histoire qui démarre sur la
pelouse de clairefontaine les bleus
s'entraînent mondial n'a pas encore
commencé mais déjà le président chirac
occupe le terrain sur l'ailé gauche
la réaction est immédiate le gardien de
la majorité reprend la balle au bond
confidence j'ai commencé ma carrière
sportive comme ball effectivement avant
de passer au basket
arrêtez les buts comme barthez les
halles ont fait les autres en rêve
j'aurais
oui la france bat le danemark et va
rencontrer l'italie en quart de finale
en voyage officiel à sienne le premier
ministre joue au tokyo avec son
homologue italien
mais à l'autre bout du monde au
mozambique jacques chirac a déjà montré
qu'il est le premier les supporters je
suis le plus heureux des hommes
et j'ai reçu des félicitations qui m'ont
touché droite au coeur de la part du
président chissano
je l'en remercie relie la france bat
l'italie aux tirs au but forcément un
tel exploit s'apprête à la métaphore je
suis un entraîneur joueur dit et annonce
de jacquet et de zidane
un président et un premier ministre qui
ne seront pas les derniers à célébrer la
victoire de la france si tout se passe
bien dimanche soir